Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We have had quite a few episodes on simulating
the motion of fluids and creating beautiful
footages from the results.
In this work, the authors created a simulator,
that shows us not only the motion of a piece
of fluid, but the physics of bubbles within
as well.
This sounds great, but there are two huge
problems: one, there are a lot of them, and
two, they can undergo all kinds of deformations
and topology changes.
To conjure up video footage that is realistic,
and relates to the real world, several bubble-related
effects, such as entrainment, splitting, merging,
advection and collapsing, all have to be simulated
faithfully.
However, there is a large body of research
out there to simulate bubbles, and here, we
are not only interested in the footage of
this piece of fluid, but also what kind of
sounds it would emit when we interact with
it.
The result is something like this.
The vibrations of a bubble is simulated by
borrowing the equations that govern the movement
of springs in physics.
However, this, by itself would only be a forlorn
attempt at creating a faithful sound simulation,
as there are other important factors to take
into consideration.
For instance, the position of the bubble matters
a great deal.
This example shows that the pitch of the sound
is expected to be lower near solid walls,
as you can see it marked with dark blue on
the left, right side and below, and have a
higher pitch near the surface, which is marked
with red.
You can also see that there are significant
differences in the frequencies depending on
the position, the highest frequency being
twice as high as the lowest.
So this is definitely an important part of
the simulation.
Furthermore, taking into consideration the
shape of the bubbles is also of utmost importance.
As the shape of the bubble goes from an ellipsoid
to something close to a sphere, the emitted
sound frequency can drop by as much as 30%.
Beyond these effects, there were still blind
spots even in state of the art simulations.
With previous techniques, a chirp-like sound
was missing, which is now possible to simulate
with a novel frequency extension model.
Additional extensions include a technique
that models the phenomenon of the bubbles
popping at the surface.
The paper discusses what cases are likely
to emphasize which of these extension's effects.
Putting it all together, it sounds magnificent,
check it out!
But still, however great these sounds are,
without proper validation, these are still
just numbers on a paper.
And of course, as always, the best way of
testing these kinds of works if we let reality
be our judge, and compare the results to real
world footage.
So I think you can guess what the next test
is going to be about!
The
authors also put up a clinic on physics and
math, and the entirety of the paper is absolutely
beautifully written.
I definitely recommend having a look, as always,
the link is available in the description box.
Also, you'll find one more link to a playlist
with all of our previous episodes on fluid
simulations.
Lots of goodies there.
As always, we'd love to read your feedback
on this episode, let us know whether you have
found it understandable!
I hope you did.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!